hey guys welcome to big mood today
before we get started we want to give a
shout out to our
newest sponsor adam and eve oh yes you
know we like sex toys
we love sex toys in this house adam and
eve is the number one
most trusted site for sex toys they've
been in business for over 50 years
they have 24 7 customer support they
also have 90 day
no hassle returns and discrete packaging
and also a really great thing is they
have 20 of their profits go to hiv
research and stuff like that that's
great 20 that's a big
20 is a huge percent um so guys go ahead
and
visit adamandeve.com and use code mood
for 50
off of one item plus free shipping in
the us and canada
some exclusions apply again that is
adamandeve.com with the code
mood for 50 off one item and free
shipping in the us
and canada with certain exclusions thank
you adam and eve
thank you dildo
sexy
yeah you could get pocket [ __ ] on
adam and eve dude you guys should
get latex molds of your vaginas and then
you should sell them on
on the big mood store and then see who
sells the most
you just want to make someone feel bad
why do you want to make your own lives
no no no no whoever sells the least
everyone's like oh [ __ ] that's okay
do you understand how what do you get
out of that people don't well
it puts you all of you against each
other really interesting let's get some
more drama
if i get a one-star review on my vagina
i'm going to jump off a [ __ ] building
well yours will
probably be a higher than one star
because you have the sideways [ __ ]
horizontal oh wow yeah
yeah you guys knew that right like the
asian [ __ ] are sideways yeah yeah
what would a what would a what would a
um one star review look like
um okay let's see one one out of five
stars uh receive the pocket [ __ ] today
i think it was molded
wrong it's sideways for example sideways
and no matter how much lube i put on it
it's just constantly like sandpaper just
soak it up yeah just soak it
up anyone notice gina's pocket [ __ ]
just soaks up all the lube
uh and in conclusion it would be
comparable to uh throwing a hot dog down
a tunnel
why is jess's [ __ ] so mean just [ __ ]
was really mean to me it was talking
[ __ ] to me while i was trying to cut
my [ __ ] has braille in there that
spells [ __ ] you
you tiny [ __ ] read this your dick is
little nikki's [ __ ] cries too much
tiffany's pocket [ __ ] comes with a
complimentary side of tahini yeah it on
there
it has flavored you it has lime juice
inside too oh my mouth just got watery
it's pretty good yummy which which one
would you choose
i gotta go with [ __ ] i gotta go
minions of course how does it cry too
much that sounds like it's a good thing
a little sprinkle of cat hair and a
little bit of steve's pubes
yeah every horse would want it yeah
everyone has their own personal touch i
think it's really beautiful yeah that's
really nice
i think it's really beautiful anyway
what are we doing here with this guy
so hi welcome to big mood
as you can see we have steve here today
because
we just wanted to ask steve a bunch of
questions without nikki there
without nikki she is behind the camera
though she's in the room though
she can't stop him she can't stop him so
we're gonna ask him a bunch of questions
that we found
on the internet on reddit like questions
that you've always wanted to ask guys
or just like random questions that i
wanted to ask steve you know because i
was in charge of the questions
so that's what we're doing today also
just segwaying to adamandeve.com
my uh my mom my my stepmom told me that
they're frequent shoppers
at that site so you just give her the
code yeah
yeah i guess you're gonna have to give
your stepmom our code she's gonna be so
proud of you
look so just for that adam and eve the
the trauma you should sponsor us forever
yeah steve it's so nice to have you
i love you guys man this is this is
awesome you're here with us you guys
really you guys really made it dude look
at this [ __ ]
shut up no it's tight i love it shut up
i actually love this set what are you
talking about i really
love it okay so are you [ __ ] on us
already
you can never talk about i'm [ __ ] on
georgia
i knew it they were just talking about
on off camera too like damn if we can
just those
george bryce and steven start a podcast
all the [ __ ] that they know about every
single
thing youtube and all the super not just
us but like all of them
these are the oldest
all right let's [ __ ] just get into it
steve you're our first
video of the day so let's [ __ ] do it
man we're going to start asking some
penetration we're all coffee high right
now but we're going in
penetrate in there all right steve can
you pee without holding your dick or
does it flop everywhere
you can you can be without holding your
dick yeah but yeah it takes discipline
does it get your balls wet
uh no not if your dick isn't that
[ __ ] tight well you think your
[ __ ] dick doesn't go past
sometimes although sometimes if your
dick is sticking to your balls that
could happen
oh that could happen so you gotta shake
it a little bit to make sure it's not if
it's not yeah if it's not limber
it also depends on the guy right because
you according to nikki you have gigantic
balls and a big dick oh they might hang
too low but you're a grower not a shower
so then that means
it's like your balls are right
there's a lot of ins and outs tell us
about your genitals
we know all about your genitals how do
you feel about him being a grower at
first did you see and you were like oh
wait no
she was a little she was a little sad
and then she was just depends right
saying grower makes you makes you think
that i have a micro penis at first
i think that's what i imagine yeah
which is not the case it's not a micro
penis everybody
i actually heard that the growing versus
the showing is better than the showing
yeah because you have a stronger
erection
when you're a grower is what i've heard
i kind of believe that okay i kind of
believe that it just depends though yeah
it does
that depends too everything depends what
else something i just noticed is that if
if this was a room full of guys asking a
girl about her vagina this would be
probably considered sexual harassment oh
true i don't care
okay so i'm just pointing that out that
we are toxic unless there was consent
and i opened this talking about all you
guys getting moldy true
you started your sexual harassment you
started yeah
we're going to meet you so bad me too so
bad after this that's okay
wait wait back to the peeing question
though so with
you really wants to know i'm jenny we're
trying to answer this correctly i'm
genuinely curious
okay so if you pee without holding your
dick doesn't it kind of like a water
hose like doesn't it kind of like go
like as strong as i stream like the
spray
i don't think that you understand
physics it's not it's not a car wash
[ __ ] advertisement thing
right i like the flailing yeah no that
that's because that has no
structure there's a structure there's a
structure to a penis right
the [ __ ] car wash like advertisement
thing has no
outside structure but you're able to
flex it which you're able to wiggle it
right i mean that's what you can flex it
but only when it's like hard
oh yeah you can only flick someone's
heart out i've never seen it once it
only goes it'll just bounce up a little
bit
it's not like it's going anywhere but
maybe a little bounced up yeah i can't
flex it right now
yeah wait and then okay another one
about the ping so with the
with the spray thing so with girl like
for us sometimes it's like a nice clean
stream and sometimes it just goes
right because when the skin is like yeah
the lips get stuck together so i wonder
if
i wonder if like the pee hole lips get
stuck together for the guys
no like in this valid question oh maybe
for circumcised guys
i don't know do you ever double stream
by accident like yeah right but that's
because of
foreskin mostly not because of just your
p hole gets clogged oh
so if you don't have a turtleneck then
your p stream is pretty clean do you
have a turtleneck
no i have like a hat i have a call that
i would call half halfy
like a like a crew so when they were
circumcising me
um they didn't cut all the way they cut
it half they didn't do all the way what
does that look like that's pretty dope
it looks majestic
that's pretty dope is your wiener two
different colors because some people
have do two different color wieners
my no it's one color oh cause you're
white yeah cause he's white yeah that's
true you gotta have a little spicy
something in you for it to have a color
oh yeah yeah well there's some whites
that get it real red sometimes
which is very unfortunate i've seen it
looks like it's in flames like a dog
penis
that's what i'm saying red rocket it
just looks like
it's like a concern i just got a blow
job from a girl with lipstick on
exactly that's what i tell myself so
that i don't think it's a dog penis oh
my god that's good
that's how you know it's not a dog
that's good i i once had sex with a guy
that that
like during the middle of dirty talk he
says yeah
i bet you want to have sex with my dog
don't you i was like whoa
hey we're gonna not do that and we're
gonna not do that what did you say
and i was just like oh because i'm not
gonna ruin the mood i'm like yeah
yeah did you guys talk about it he's
like he's like
okay we're moving on moving on moving on
moving on
um next question do you guys talk to
your guy friends about the girl that you
like
ever like you like just sweet things
yeah sweet things
uh okay it depends on the guy right like
i know plenty of guys that
i know not to talk that way around
because it's they don't have any
depth there yeah like they're not
emotionally available so they don't want
to hear your emotions
exactly so you got to read the room and
kind of be like oh okay like
this is not the guy to talk like about
how much i love my wife or any of that
kind of [ __ ] right but you do if there's
a right guy
yeah if it's the mood's right and then
if there's a reason to i don't just like
start going man i love my wife
you do it to us all the time there's got
to be a reason though that's true
um and also when guys talk about the
girl they're dating is it really that
vulgar because there's a lot of stories
you hear about like guys are always
talking about yeah i
trained her and her vagina was like
sometimes yeah it's like it's almost
like a exercise
yeah it's like you're pitching almost
you're just [ __ ] around with each
other
about it but i can't say that i've heard
a lot of that
locker room talk yeah i i know about it
right but i can't say i've heard of
maybe you're the guy that other guys say
like oh steve's not the guy that i just
disrespect women in front of that's
right steve [ __ ] around though
i can't wait to [ __ ] around but yeah i
don't really i don't do the the whole
like
yeah [ __ ] maybe it's more like bro
guys yeah yeah
i don't think you're really a bro guy
yeah so have guys done that to you and i
was just like what the [ __ ]
i can't remember that no yeah that means
you're surrounded by good people see you
make a good decision i do
have a lot of good good people around me
for sure good good
um let's see i i mean i talk about nikki
in a vulcan way all the time so i can't
relate
so do i though next question
if you have to pee dirt i like how this
just was why did you pick so many pee
things it's just i don't know it was
just there i found this on right now
you're trying to tell us that you have a
pee
fetish i have a question to ask you guys
after talking about this actually
if you have to pee during a [ __ ] do you
get back up or do you just sit down and
just continue oh yeah just keep going
oh so your dick's already in there yeah
yeah oh it's in there you don't put on
your lap and sit
legs closed you don't hot dog it no what
do you think is happening in there
like i think that you guys sit with your
legs closed why why do their legs have
to be yeah
but i still squat with my legs together
oh but your dick's not like up
you don't i don't i don't have my legs
wide open either kind of like no i
i'm definitely a wide open oh you're a
bra pooper
yeah i'm a pretty i'm in the middle all
around i'm offended that you think that
we keep our dick out i just thought that
seems very strangely feminine that they
would be sitting there with their knees
touching
i feel like this on my phone and then my
legs go numb so my knees are together
you don't no your dicks flops okay it
just hangs it's just sweet
just hangs it wobbles to and fro and
then you just pee while you're pooping
yeah oh okay very relaxing oh does it
ever happen to you when you're peeing
like standing and then you realize you
have to poop so after you pee
then you end up sitting down like does
that ever happen to you no that doesn't
happen to me but it happens with my
buddy bart a lot
shits himself standing up oh gosh oh my
god actually
his son does that i watched tyka [ __ ]
standing up
he shut the pool right the other day
yeah it was two people i was in their
pool
and tycho was in there and he he just
all of a sudden he goes oh no
and then he gets out of the water and
then he just immediately took a [ __ ]
standing up
i don't care like on because they have
the concrete
coming over if you're listening to this
eight years from now send this video to
taika yeah make fun of them
definitely don't do that
oh no high school graduation high school
graduation video
we'll put all that together leave tycho
alone leave them alone
so what are some little things that
you've done for girls for nicki if
you know that they just that they don't
notice that nikki might not have noticed
what's in little sweet things oh that's
cute
little things yeah that you like
intentionally were like
because i think she's gonna enjoy this
yeah i'm gonna do this
um do you think that your gestures go
unnoticed by girls
at all no okay i and i think if anything
it's a little much sometimes because
we're in the public sphere
a little bit right and so if i do
something
a lot of people hear about it in all
these different shows so like not only
do they hear about on my podcast they
hear about on your guys podcast they
hear about on jk
they hear about it like four different
times so i just sound like the greatest
guy on the earth yep
that's ever lived and it's not really
how i feel so
you know i just tried to we're selling
yourself short because i hear this [ __ ]
yesterday we were having a meeting and
nikki's like oh honey can you
airdrop me this thing from my computer
and then you added a line that said
oh just i love my wife or something like
that something's super cute i'm like
[ __ ] whose boyfriend or husband would
do that
i just like her that's it i love my wife
that's it she's okay yeah she's like but
there's plenty of chicks who would tell
you i was addicted to them or whatever
so i i just because they were the wrong
girl i guess exactly though exactly
but when you love a lady that's right
you'll do
but you're not just universally
that's what i get for trying to be
serious
that's why i can't find my man because i
don't know what happens when he loves a
woman then what
he can't keep his mind on nothing else
okay i don't know
actually he knows the [ __ ] words to
that he knows it though and that's why
he is no bad
he does know it i know he does he
probably sings it to nicki every night
before bed
i would say that i try to um
when things are when nikki's like
spinning out because for whatever reason
i try to be the calm presence but she
does the same thing for me
if i am if i am being an anger monster
in our house she's very chill during
that it's not like it's
all the time steve is like rock resolute
like if i am doing that she does the
same [ __ ] yeah absolutely
and that goes i witnessed but that goes
on said a lot because
we all [ __ ] around a lot and i love to
make fun of nikki as well
but but she's very like she matches the
energy of
whatever like she kind of counters the
energy of whatever's happening in a
really helpful way
yeah she does that for us too when we're
[ __ ] raging our minds out
she's our voice of reason she's held us
back from making a lot of mistakes yeah
i could have gotten to a lot of trouble
she probably kept me
possibly out of jail at least and that
goes on notice
because we all just think about nikki
and like oh she's crying probably laying
on the floor right now right yeah
which is which is part of nikki too but
but that that that other part doesn't
get set up she's
very mature very mature i also just try
to clean the [ __ ] up a little bit more
now
like i just cleaned our floors really
good the other day and like
that's what i've heard you suck at
cooking and you're dirty
i know i'm trying to but i'm trying to
be cleaner that's good no you can't
you can't be better yeah you have to
stay you're already right that's enough
too much we're sitting in the bar real
high for the people on youtube right now
well look dude
too high i clean those clean those
floors so good that i take personal
pride and seeing them shine now
would you ever piss on those floors
why because we just have asked so many
questions about people oh i understand
now
i would would you clean up again would
you clean up nikki's piss
on the floor yeah wiper and wiper yeah
yeah sure
he would do that for us too i think so
too like he's such a
here's some paper towels to wipe
yourself maybe maybe if i could lift
your legs up like a baby
then maybe i would do that the reason
why i say that is because we did this
one article where this guy
he was asking reddit whether or not it
was wrong of him
to help clean because he's a nurse too
that's an added factor
but like a friend came over they had
like a bigger party this girl ended up
getting so wasted she ended up pooping
herself and
this dude's wife which is was there too
she ended up leaving she was too drunk
to clean
so this dude ends up like helping his
friend cleans her and wipes her
and like quickly like wipes but i'm like
honestly steve
like i thought like if you were a nurse
that totally is you like you would help
if that happened to you at a party sure
i'd think i think i would do that
it just depends me down dude i would
just gina down for sure
yeah i'll imagine steve just yeah
spraying gina is a whole host
from afar tim is a wet wipes gina is a
host yeah oh
no like i don't even care if it's in the
middle of summer and the water comes out
hot first
sure well that's better yeah naturally
what's the next question well i have a
question for you
oh thank you tiff do you guys like
comfortable
socks do you like to wear the most
comfortable socks in the world like i am
wearing right now i'm wearing bombas
so they make the most comfortable socks
in the history of feet
i've had these socks guys i'm wearing
these socks this is such a foot fetish
moment oh that was a foot covered up
it's covered
they look they look old because i've had
these socks for over five years
like they last oh really yes and in the
last five years
check this out so like i said it's
they're old socks okay but they
bump as the reason why i absolutely love
them is because it's like a gel strip
there's like this
like exactly like this like strip that
keeps them on
so you know how like low-cut socks
they're always slip off and they're like
the most annoying thing ever that fills
me with uncontrollable rage when i'm
walking
yes yeah but not with bombas and that's
why i've had these socks for over five
years and that's why i'm so happy and
proud that they are sponsoring this
podcast
and like i said i wear them i've been
wearing these socks for many years
they're super comfortable
and not only that but with every pair of
socks you purchase bombas donates a pair
to someone in need
we love philanthropy yeah exactly so the
generosity of bombast customers has
allowed them to donate over 34 million
pairs of socks and
counting through their nationwide
network of 3 000 plus giving partners
and the impact is more powerful than
ever uh to those experiencing
homelessness
these socks represent the dignity of
putting on clean clothes a small comfort
that's especially important
right now so give a pair when you buy a
pair and get 20
off your first purchase at bombas.com
mood that's
bombas so b-o-m-b-a-s
dot com slash mood for twenty percent
off your first purchase bombast.com
mood love these socks guys i do i really
do
and back to pee questions okay well
before we get into that
let's talk about my hair first i see um
our sponsor today is function of beauty
hair care
one size fits all may work for your
accessories but when it comes to your
hair
we all need something a little bit
different to help us look our best
what if your hair care was as unique as
you were
i just washed my hair this morning with
function of beauty oh my god it smells
really good
so function of beauty is a hair care
formula or a hair care product that's
formulated just for you
you go on their website you take a quiz
and tell them
what you want to change about your hair
and then they make a formula for you and
it's fully customizable you can
customize the color
the smell and then the bottle comes
named after you too
uh personally i have a purple one it's
peach and it says function of gina on it
um tiff i'm sure you have something for
your your hair color your blue blue yeah
teal
it's a teal bottle um function of beauty
has over 54 trillion
possible ingredient combinations to make
sure your formula
is unique is as unique as you because
i'm dry as hell
trillion trillion math man wow
so functional beauty's team determines
the right blend of ingredients then
bottle your custom formula to order
the formulas are vegan and cruelty free
they never use sulfates parabens or any
other
harmful ingredients then they deliver
your personalized formula right to your
door in a cute customized bottle
with your favorite color and fragrance
they even print your name on it and you
can choose to have a little pump thing
on it too which i love
my specific formula i got is for colored
hair bleached hair and also
my scalp is dry as heck and i have very
thin hair
i am balding so that's my personal
formula and it's working it smells
amazing i smell like a peach every day
so what are you waiting for go to
functionalbeauty.com big mood to take
your four-part
hair profile quiz and take 20 off your
first
order go to functionalbeauty.com
big mood for 20 off and let them know
that you heard about it from our show
that's so that they know that we're
doing our job well that's
functionalbeauty.com
all right steve good read thanks i'm
actually impressed
thank you i really am oh wow you know
why i thought you wouldn't do that well
what it's because of the way i look
honestly
i'm a lot smarter than i look
um all right steve let's let's move on
uh
do you wish as a man do you wish that
you were
complimented more praised more because
there's
a lot of people say that men don't get
as much praise and compliments
or there's like a meme that says men get
one compliment they hold on to it
forever because they don't get it often
oh that's sad it's really sad um wow
that's devastating
i'm not that guy i get it though if
you're in an environment where you don't
feel appreciated or something like that
like it just depends on who you are also
personality type and like love language
type because i think words of
affirmation guys
would relate to that right yeah and i
mean you know
i think just i don't i can't think about
i can't think that i i need a compliment
per se
i always feel very awkward getting a
compliment i have anything
right but but that's just a part of that
doesn't make any better than anybody
some people like need that like but yeah
i think it's more of a love language
thing almost
yeah i'm the same way i think when
people compliment me i'm like oh no get
it off
i get yeah it's weird right yeah yeah i
get kind of um
when they compliment me i feel the need
to compliment back
but then also if you struggle you're
like oh well i like uh
you know they're they're [ __ ] ugly
because there's nothing i'm kidding i'm
just kidding but
to me i feel like i need to compliment
back but that also makes me feel kind of
disingenuous
just because it complimented me yes so i
learned that when someone compliments
you just
gracefully say thank you yeah that was
me too so before i used to be like jess
and
like people would compliment me and be
like oh no no no like i i i felt like i
had to
prove them why they were like prove to
them why they were
incorrect yeah where i'm like i don't
feel like this about me how how are you
like you're smart you're like no i'm not
yeah yeah it's so dumb it was like that
in the past but then it got to a point
where i forgot who it was i feel like it
was my sister or someone
but they ended up getting annoyed and
they're just like just take the
compliment just accept it like
you don't have to like debate it just
accept it and i'm like
oh [ __ ] that's true that is annoying
that i have to fight the compliment it's
like yeah why can't i just accept it so
now i just i do that too
thank you steve have you ever gotten a
compliment that you still remember till
this day that's very unique unique
uh unique
they're all basic yeah i mean they're
all well no people are really nice
i i like especially when i go to like
any of the cons or like the vidcons or
the
playlists lives or that people coming up
and saying they watch me since they're a
kid or whatever or um
you know people like oh man you're a
legend dude like i've seen you forever
and all that stuff that's all nice but
um it sucks because
i'm trying to sound weird about this but
i can't accept
that compliment and go yes i am a legend
right right
yeah and then also get a hate comment
and go well i don't accept that right
so to me you have to not accept either
maybe from the public but from people in
your life right accept things
if like [ __ ] bill murray came up to
me he's like yo steve that was funny or
something i
i would lose my [ __ ] probably [ __ ] on
the floor right but
somebody that i don't know but but they
know me and and i understand that
i can't i can't let myself go to the
moon over that yeah
or i will get an annoying ego which i've
seen a million times
in this space did you did you grow up
with the whole like um
i feel like it's pretty common the man
up mentality where men don't show
emotions
oh hell yeah being a [ __ ] hell yeah i'm
trying to get better about that
it's in my own life yeah right oh yeah i
was
a sad boy about two years ago and i
couldn't i
never really wanted to admit it and uh
yeah eventually like me and nikki we're
doing like a
uh we do a podcast called [ __ ] they
don't tell you after dark on our patreon
thing
and i like broke down during the thing
when she asked me she's like what do you
ever what do you do for yourself
and i i started crying i was like i
don't do anything for myself i haven't
done anything for myself in a long time
and uh yeah you know i think when i lost
my youtube channel
i just sort of spiraled out for a while
thinking about all the work i put into
it
yeah and all that stuff and how you know
you don't get anything for it
in the end did you feel like you weren't
allowed to feel anything about it
yeah i wasn't i wasn't allowed to [ __ ]
about it you know especially when you
look at
the real problems of the world and stuff
it's like that's so small but
you know it's your own thing that you
feel like you built it's like it's like
um you ever see the video video of a
this grown man
gets his legos stolen no no it's very
when you think about this video it's a
grown man crying about
how he got his legos stolen and like
destroyed and stuff
but it's really sad to see he is he
built those legos he loves his legos
probably shouldn't be playing with legos
anymore but he loves it
you know what i'm saying so if it feels
a bit like that when i'm talking about
my youtube channel i'm like
i built it it was fun i like that and so
it's like a part of your identity
yeah i i don't like it when people say
well what are you sad about there's
worse out there there's other people who
have it worse that's like saying well
what are you so happy about there's
happier people
don't be happy if you try to do that to
everything you can not have fun ever but
yeah
um it's important to yeah to realize why
things are happening so i wasn't asking
myself why i was upset
i was just plowing through and so um
yeah i hate all that [ __ ] like uh just
be tough and stuff well
what have what changed then after that
breakdown like what did you start doing
i started i mean actually working out
and [ __ ] taking care of myself not
eating stupid [ __ ] all the time and
you know i don't know it just it's all
about
but it's a daily thing you can't just
like it's not like oh because that
happened
i'm over it it's more like no now i have
to like
every day remind myself to not be that
way you know what i'm saying
so yeah it's still it's still something
that i'm working at but
it's a good it's a good mindset to
acknowledge that i
oh i did that and here's why i did that
and i need to be better than that
i think you're so great at being very uh
emotionally open and communicative
because i remember talking to you and
you said to me
i think it's [ __ ] lame how guys are
always like at a bar
like yeah dude i'm gonna give that guy a
piece of my mind i'm gonna tell him i'm
just gonna say it man that's how i am
bro
yeah that's how i say what i think i
can't help it bro but they can't say it
to their significant other or their
people in their lives like they can't
open up
yeah like that's [ __ ] made right and
they think it's [ __ ] made
to not say what they think in a bar but
then at home with their wife or whoever
they can't say their feelings that's
more important i think it's the same
yeah
if you're that guy then why can't you be
that guy in all facets
yeah i try to be that way i try to be
that way um
let's see well i'm glad you're making
progress thank you i'm happy for you
yeah thank you very much
how do you feel about the woman doing
the more
quote man thing like proposing first or
asking out on it asking you out right
now oh yeah because nikki
warned you she was like if he does not
propose to me
i am going to propose to you she knew i
was gonna propose really
this was not stretched out this makes it
sound like i was
dating her for 10 years and i wouldn't
get off the couch
but she knew i was going to propose
first of all how did you know how did
she know
she knew when we were there bo like she
knew
chicks know stuff man
but like so as far as generally though a
guy and a girl are together should the
girl
should the girl i can't do the girl ever
make the first move
always lead first move is one thing
because you're just saying you like
somebody
from like stranger to hey we've met now
that's it
but then after that the girl has to just
no i don't think so
i think if it's just about being honest
if you really feel away
then be honest about it what if the girl
really feels like she wants to marry the
guy and she doesn't want to wait
bud getting down on one knee to a man i
can't help but laugh i'm sorry i laugh
every time
i see that at an nba game or something
yeah like any of those video
compilations of people getting rejected
and [ __ ]
instantly the guy loses his street cred
if he says yes it's so
it's just i i it's probably a horrible
thing that i even think that way
but it's just so goddamn funny-looking
to me
i i can never i can't be that person and
i'm sorry like if you can do it
good for you you're strong i can't do it
it's a little old-fashioned of course it
is yeah because i agree with you guys
too i'm like
i wouldn't i wouldn't want to yeah if i
had to propose to the guy
i would feel like yeah it's hard yeah
it's almost like
well [ __ ] the power dynamic is so
strange now yeah
if you were to propose to the guy and he
said yes i feel like the woman should
just carry him out
but then also it's like the girl loves
him so much that he can do anything he
can walk all over her he can because she
what she like
wanted him so bad that she went
completely against the normal
[ __ ] like you know suiting rules or
whatever it's weird he's like well you
wanted me
so you want me that bad well you know i
can cheat i can do whatever i want
i can see that's what i'm thinking
that's like the extreme version i know i
go i go
[ __ ] extreme you blow over
immediately yeah
i could see it both ways though right i
could see either a [ __ ] [ __ ] or he's
like
gonna take advantage of it right no but
i could see it where
because i always i always just see
everything through a lens of funniness
because it keeps things lighter and i'm
just a more positive person because of
it
but i could see where somebody's just
like man i love this person so much
i want to marry them and i want to do
something sweet because i'm more of like
a
i'm more of the sweeter one in this
relationship so i could do probably do a
better
job maybe it's something like that i
don't know but i can't help but laugh
at the visual that's all i'm laughing at
the visual
i get the tenderness and the what's
going on behind the scenes
yeah can't do it for hetero couples it's
just like i don't know it's just a
lesbian couple it's just cute
[ __ ] yeah it's a whole different thing
there's no real rules for them i feel
like but i don't know
yeah i just wouldn't feel right i have a
family member that's like uh
the moment they started dating she's
like well i want to get married so you
better propose soon
and it felt more like he was kind of
forced to
you know like wouldn't you want him to
do it on his own to want to
you know yeah dude i've seen some like
hostage videos like that
yeah for sure like i was uh at one
and i watched a relative
basically this guy gets like walked out
and basically put on his knees with the
ring in his hand
like all the relatives like shepherd him
shepherded him there
this chick like set up a party had it
all ready to go
and it was like before getting people
had to like show up and then
like yeah dude like they basically put a
dog collar on him and walked
they [ __ ] walked him and i watched he
brings the ring at least like his
on his own or like the family provided
the ring too no no he got the ring right
but but the way that it all happened it
was like being at the zoo and sometimes
you look at an animal and you're like
they're not really here
they're broken their spirit is broken i
watched this guy like a horse
yeah dude he gets like [ __ ] walked in
the room put
put down on one knee and the way that he
like scooped the ring up
i was like he's not he's not there his
his body has
not no one's left his butt in there
i don't know man jesus christ that's we
should not be forcing love
a broken man are they still together
yeah dude they're
getting married oh my god that's
terrible i know someone who got married
once
because just because we should i mean we
might as well you know oh i know a lot
of people i almost had to tell you
you did come close that's right you guys
have to be stopped
yep yes yeah by your bad friends who
broke you up yeah
it's such a great relationship god is it
funny
um so the next question is
how hard is it to ask a girl out and how
hard is it in the dating scene for a guy
because honestly chicks you just have to
go outside
that's true just [ __ ] go outside then
for guys you have to like muster up the
courage and like figure out the
the tactic like or like the verbiage and
how to articulate and that's a lot of
pressure it just depends on who you are
right like if you're out there and
you're not good at talking to people
then i can see that being like a
mountain to climb right but
if you can talk to people and still and
then and then imagine
you're nervous because this person's
like you like this person
so now you're not going to talk to
people and you're nervous like holy [ __ ]
god yeah
that is a hard combo did nikki ever make
you nervous yeah hell yeah on our first
date i
i didn't even drive in the right
direction i drove
i drove us near where where george and
bryce live
and and where we were going was burbank
like it was like
the complete opposite direction so your
brain stopped working because you're so
nervous 100
and i'm just making a conversation with
her and it was i was just nervous and
yeah
oh that's sweet yeah that's so sweet but
every time we pass that street now we
always
laugh at that at the first date because
one day i was driving out there and uh
this is actually just the other day
and i was like i had to be driving for
like 45 minutes because this was
pre-covered
at times like i had to be driving for 45
minutes
in the wrong direction that's a long
time
so okay so when it comes to dating and
asking a girl out because we get this
question all the time
and we can give them our answer or
perspective but
if you can give advice to the guys out
there how would you ask girl on a date
how would you do it what's the best way
to do it
uh so when you when you want to ask
somebody out right
there's there's a way of doing it that's
not so
um deep right or sounds so
crazy like hey do you want to go on a
date with me
it's a little bit high stakes right but
if it's like so
in the intonation too it's like it all
matters well yeah it just makes it
higher stakes than it needs to be
it could be it could sound way chiller
than that and then kind of
while you're there you tricked him onto
a date right now no but um
for example implications with nikki i
was like we're talking about this movie
that's coming out right
and uh we're just rapping about it and i
was like oh we should go see it
you know what i mean and that's it it
was very simple and i was like oh when
are you free when you want to do it
and then she wasn't even sure if it was
a date right
but then i texted her and i was like yo
just so you know you're not paying a
dime for this [ __ ] like i'm
i'm taking care of that or whatever like
just to make sure that it was lacquered
with
understanding that it's a date before we
got there but i mean like we might
like some of us are dumb and just still
be like oh maybe he's just a really nice
guy
so what about more like straightforward
at that point i mean when you see that
when the guy shows up in a tuxedo
oh you'll know it's a date you didn't
did you wear tuxedo guys with tails
but to be honest if a guy's like hey we
should go see that movie and it's a guy
it's a man you know i'm like immediately
i'm like well okay do i want this to be
a date or do i not want this to be a
date
and if i'm not okay with it being a date
i'm not going to go
yeah right so i feel like you're not
actually doing anything to super
embarrass yourself
by being like hey we should go see that
it's it's less of like a proposal
exactly so then i'm like oh no i don't
it's okay i don't really want to go you
know like
then you're like well i just turned you
down for to go see a movie versus like
to be your soul mate yeah and it depends
sometimes
it's kind of cool to be like yo let's go
out i want to go out i want to go out
with you
like that can be really cool too but if
you're the type of person who's like
oh i'm worried about getting rejected or
any of that kind of thing there's a less
high-stakes way of going about it right
and you need to learn how to take
rejection well
you need to learn how to rejection well
too i thought you said you need to learn
how to inject her well
i mean i was like whoa gina i mean
that'll get you past the first
few weeks dude reject it you need to
take rejection while
it's that's a big thing yeah because if
a girl is like hey gina do you want to
go out
no i don't want to go out with a [ __ ]
[ __ ] anyway oh yeah yeah right
that's how you handle that that's [ __ ]
that's how your hand is [ __ ] ugly
[ __ ] behavior i've ever seen that
happens all the time right it happens a
lot
and it really highlights how insecure
the guy is and it just makes them that
much more unattractive it's wild yeah
how they think that that's cool though
or like or when they don't get the point
too
because like i went on a date with this
guy once we just had drinks at this
place
it was like i just met him online and we
just met and then after it was over i
was like okay well he's not really my
type but then he just kept texting and
kept and i'm like hey you know it's not
really
i don't think there's enough chemistry
or whatever it's not really a thing and
he was just like are you sure
please can we try again i think we
should try again like like begging for a
second date and i was just like
and i literally texted him i said bro
this is not helping you oh
you need to stop and then the next day
he texted me again
some meme that like it was related to my
brother or something because my
brother's in the military
and i'm like bro now i have to block
your number because like
you're like bro i have two dogs stop i
don't need a third dog yeah
good lord sounds weird it's just so
strange to me that they they go straight
on the attack
and it makes no sense either like it
doesn't they all
all um common sense goes out the window
because i remember some guy was like
cat calling me he's like some girl blah
blah and i'm just like
sorry i'm not interested he goes well
you're ugly anyways so i turned around
i'm like
then why did you hit on me yeah and then
he walked into the taco bell
i think it's like taking it personally
he went into the taco bell to order
yeah like to sit down probably and eat
too yeah exactly
then well i mean what were you wearing
that day though oh maybe if he dressed
better
i would have said yes if he's wearing a
tuxedo if he was wearing a tuxedo yeah
going into the taco bell well i don't
know about tuxedos but i do know about
you know
general fashion and what i do know about
general fashion is that shopping makes
me [ __ ] anxious
you give me anxiety and i hate it
like i wear the most basic [ __ ] all the
time because like trying to put fashion
together is just so annoying for me
which is why i love stitch fix
you guys love stitch fix i love stitch
fixtures because trying on clothes in
the mall
is a lot of work well also now with
kobit like i don't want to be breathing
in other people's stuff
i would like for my clothes to come to
me stitchfix is a company that will put
together fashion for you
send it to you in a little box you get
to choose what you like what you don't
like you can send some of it back or you
can keep it all
and get a little discount they are a
personal styling company
it's a completely fun and different way
to find clothes that you will love
that's all about you every time so
sometimes actually there was a shirt
that i got that i never would have got
i never would have bought if i'd seen it
in person but they actually sent it to
me and i tried it on and i was like oh i
actually do like this
style this cut of shirt so i wouldn't
have tried it if i wasn't forced to try
it and i thought that was fun
um so what you do is you pay a 20
styling fee for each fix and it's
credited towards anything you keep
and you can schedule your fix at any
time you don't have to stick to a
subscription
uh shipping returns and exchanges are
easy and free stitch fix does all the
hard work for you
making your style effortless and they
also have stuff for
men and kids cool so if you're too busy
right now get started today at
stitchfix.com
mood and you'll get 25 off when you keep
everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.com mood for 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
one more time what was that
spitfix.com
that's right and while you're looking
good you want to feel good too and
how do you feel good by making sure that
you are in taking some healthy food
right because you got to take care of
your body
so right now daily harvest is helping me
beat the heat with their refreshing
delicious healthy smoothies and scoops
with their new plant-based ice cream
scoops are free of additives
preservatives and fillers because
they're made with whole
nourishing organic ingredients
ingredients like black sesame coconut
cream and dragon fruit
and they have four amazing flavors
eating clean food with daily harvest is
easy and effortless whether you're
having a night at home or
need a quick bite on the go everything
stays fresh in your freezer until you're
ready to enjoy
it they have these really cool bowls
that you could just put in the microwave
and then
you're ready to go there's no food prep
like no cooking nicki's obsessed with it
like like she eats it every day i'm not
kidding exactly so keep it simple this
summer with daily harvest go to
dailyharvest.com and enter promo code
big mood to get 25 off your first
box that's promo code big mood for 25
off your first box at dailyharvest.com
that's dailyharvest.com promo code
big mood all right nutritious
yes back to delicious very nutritious
indeed
well i mean there is one question that i
want to ask and i feel like every guy
should try this have tried this probably
did but won't admit it
have you tried sucking your own dick
because if i can do it
bro of course i would never need a
girlfriend so how close did you get to
it
close because your limber is
because it's that long dude i was like i
was like i was like 14 and i was like
i could probably suck my own [ __ ] it
was one of those things it wasn't like
oh this will be sexual for me yeah
i was like i could probably do more fun
picturing you right now grown ass man
yeah yeah yeah you're trying to attempt
this no please picture a 14 year old
instead
yeah yeah no no no no no no i don't want
to do that
oh okay are you sure okay yeah so but it
was morally just the thing because
everyone's talking about how you suck
can you suck your own dick and [ __ ] and
i was like i don't know can i i don't
know
but i i wasn't a i didn't do it okay you
didn't try it i did not do it
wait you but you reached for it i tried
to see if i could actually
reach it right now i have a story kind
of related to that so the
the second date that i was on with this
guy that i dated earlier this year
we somehow were joking around and it got
really raunchy and then i said something
about sucking your own dick and then
um and then i was like i wonder if like
there's porn of guys sucking their own
dick because there's porn of everything
right
so me and this guy the second day that
we're hanging out we started googling
like guys sucking their own dick because
i wanted to see if it was possible
because i thought
it's not possible that's why there was
that rumor of marilyn manson having to
take ribs out
in order to be able to do it i'm like
it's not possible right
there's porn and there's guys that are
able to do it i mean wow but also there
was this one video that we found where
this guy
this guy was trying so hard but he
couldn't reach it but the video the
guy's just like
like and you see him like you catch it
he like he like he like kept like uh
uh like he was he was like forcing
trying to reach
that fetish it was a weird [ __ ] video
and then he edits it and he's like this
is
good i uploaded it putting this up and
me and that guy were just [ __ ]
cracking up and like it was kind of an
inside joke for a little while because
every time like something funny would
happen we would just go
you know i'm trying to reach your own
dick you know like
i thought you were gonna say i was on
this date with this guy and i was joking
about
sucking his own dick and then he got
quiet and then he did it
i was like oh well would that be a
problem
if a guy told me he could do it i would
be more likely to go to his house to
see it i see yeah so because i like i
want to see it i'm like
oh that's [ __ ] weird and nasty yeah
let me see it right
let me see you do it it's kind of hot
it's kind of hot it's kind of it's so
weird and gross that it's hot yeah wow i
don't know if i could get turned on by
that i don't know if i would be either
but i'm willing to find out
that's a dominant thing for me that's
like when a guy is like hey you want to
see my wound
my open wound my festering [ __ ] wound
i'm like how is it like that
that's me it's that same kind of like
that's me yeah yeah it's not you don't
suck your own dick that's not just i
don't want to watch you suck your own
dick though that's my thing
i mean because you're a guy oh yeah
that's right i'm a girl
wait if you could see a girl lick
herself would you want to see that
yeah she would be bendy
yeah i've seen people get in those
positions the circus light people can
deep throw their own dicks
yeah they can eat their own ass probably
i'm sure yeah [ __ ] yeah
actually i'm down to watch that i wish i
could do that too if you're in cirque du
soleil please
dm me there it is that'd be very
pleasurable though because now i'm
trying to
picture like the logistics of it all and
i'm like i'm like bent over
i'm getting myself off when i'm when i'm
really like
reaching orgasm my whole body gets
[ __ ] tense so i wouldn't
be able to like what gina
what china mortis oh sorry go ahead
no but yeah so then i'm like wait your
body turns into like a [ __ ] steel rod
sometimes if the orgasm is really really
like it's basically
bombing out i've never done
dude you know how hot that would be if
i'm like dominating guy i'm like no [ __ ]
you you suck your own dick oh she's the
dominant one
yeah that'd be dope that'd be so dark i
don't think i would do it that way i
would just be like wow
i'm not usually the dominant one but
that'd be it'd be useful for me i'd get
all up in there like
so this is how it works like oh [ __ ] can
you show me how you like it
do it the way that oh [ __ ] that's that
would be cool
but then like do you think like if a guy
could do that he'll just be like no one
can do it like i can
oh that could happen that's scary yeah
that is
kind of like because me i come more from
masturbation than
from sex with another person like no one
can do it the way i can i can come in 30
seconds or less
because you haven't had the right
because you hadn't done it because you
hadn't done it with me yet
yeah yeah was just waiting [ __ ] girl
you know
dude seriously this one guy too he was
like oh i'm so good at sex and i'm so
good at like eating out [ __ ] bubble
blah so like i'm like okay that was the
douchiest thing i've ever heard but i'll
let it slide
and then we go on a few dates and then
when he does it i was like [ __ ] what
that's so sick expectations he takes
your pants off and he starts falling
asleep i even know
no i even told him too i was like oh i
bet you're one of those guys that thinks
that you just
like when you're eating a [ __ ] you just
jam your fingers and back as far as you
possibly can
and trying to [ __ ] try to flick my
foot
and so i was just like you know some
guys don't know you you cannot you could
go in just a little bit and it's great
like you don't have to [ __ ] jam your
fingers all the way to the far back
and then the first thing he does is jam
his fingers all the way to the far back
and he's just like tickling my [ __ ]
uh insides i'm like no bro bring it back
he's like where's your womb i can't find
your room
oh gosh that's where the the [ __ ] is
right
yeah right like inside the cervix the
[ __ ] liver
no thank you jesus christ i feel like
any guy that has to brag like that is
just
yeah i'm learning like how to figure out
based on signs
like where it's gonna go yeah i dated a
guy once because we
we met online and then me being me i
stocked everything and i found
everything so i found his facebook
and there was a video of him standing
there and uh like every it was just like
a surprise birthday party of some sort
and he just standing there and he had
light pants on and there was a
there was a bulge i think i sent it to
you girl oh you did it like he had it
looked like he had a boner
yeah like it was it was just a huge
bulge and i said to the girls i'm like
guys
are you seeing what i'm seeing and then
they're like yeah it's not to be true
she was happy when she said that
dressing dick faces fantastic
that's great i kind of want to see if
steve
can give me advice as a single female
and
other single females who have my
personality type can take note as well
i know i'm a hot mess but steve you're
well put together
you're seeing me in a shitty
relationship yes and now you see me kind
of going through my whole face because
i'm like
i'm breaking free [ __ ] i was in prison
for five years
but then now like getting to a place to
where i could get a relationship like
maybe you can read me
tell me like what i should be doing what
would be helpful
what i shouldn't be what you should be
doing to get to a relationship is that
what you yeah maybe
i mean not right probably because you're
in the football team football team phase
right now
but is it and then how do you feel about
that football team phase i love it i'm
happy for you
you're the one who told me you're like
you texted me in case you're like i'm
ready to get railed by a football team
or something
good for you i was like how many guys
are in a football team like thirty two
fifty three now oh there's fifty three
guys okay well kidding i don't know if
i'm gonna get it did that mean
well maybe it's just guys on the field
right so it's like it's 12 minutes
people are on a basketball team
uh i don't know that's a lot less i
think it's like eight
yeah on a whole team oh no but on the on
the court yeah like how many guys
belong to the lakers you're supposed to
know this steve i don't know that i
don't know
i only know football so you know there's
people there's many guys jesus
there's 50 guys in the dallas cowboys
there's fifty dollars three now fifty
three
how do they afford to pay that many
football players and they're all getting
like tens of millions there actually
might be 54 soon because the new cba but
uh on the field 12 men 12 men on the
field so you can okay that's what we're
shooting for
i don't know if i can handle 50 new
dicks i believe in you this is fine i
think you can
you can you can do it in a weekend
what's your body count
i don't even know you don't even know i
have no idea well if you would guess
it's over 20. is it under the amount of
football players on a team
yes okay i lost count at 20 but that was
before joe and then so now it's been my
single year
oh you could easily catch back up then
so you feel that you have sewed your
wild oats though you're not necessarily
looking to bang
no i i mean i've definitely sewn
sewn all the oats that i need to sew um
entire cereal factory
yeah raisins i could definitely
supply a third world country with
cheerios
um she's such a philanthropist i love it
right this is what i like how this
conversation is half like from little
women in half like from now
yeah like sewn have you sewn your wild
oats have you ever
you brought it up i know it's just so
i'm just i'm just noticing it so then
now now what's your response to that
um no i think i mean if you do want a
relationship you just need to write down
all the things you want
yeah it's time it's time to actually
make a list of all the [ __ ] that you
want and then
what about the things that i like
because the things that i want are
stupid
what are you i'm like i want a guy that
like like listens to this band
well it has to be like right now
breakers
prioritize if that band is your [ __ ]
life though
like like nikki with eminem dude i have
to listen to eminem
yeah yeah she's like she's not in here
right now everywhere i go we listen to
[ __ ] eminem i can't stand her anymore
yeah that's driving me crazy
it would drive me crazy i do need help i
think so i guess like but just things
do you think i'm gonna miss my husband
if i'm like oh i want someone with a
similar taste in music
am i gonna am i gonna miss my husband if
i'm like oh you listen to country music
sorry what's the priority right is this
guy making you laugh
doing all this cool [ __ ] he [ __ ] you
right all the things that you want
and he's like respectful and like all
right i feel like giving country music
there's a give and take jess damn it
listen i'm going to be a priority here
i'm with you on country music
yeah it's not a name
you guys are thinking but like the older
one but it still gets a little tiny
where i'm like
please no can you turn it off yeah do
you like pina colada
i'm like i'm out i'm out
so what would you say for jess can she
should she still just
you know play the field well yeah but
you but she
cause she hasn't found the guy yet yeah
so play the field but have a list of all
the things
what if i'm playing the field wrong what
if you play the field too much how do
you know if it's too much
i think you recently played the field
wrong how let me know
read me steve okay well so you were
dating this guy
yeah um and you were kind of
uh momming him a little bit instead of
trying to
be in a relationship with him you were
trying to force him to be what you need
yeah because he was like partying too
much though
no it's fine but he's got to be his own
person yeah yeah and
that's that i think where you maybe had
a little bit of a a little bit of a
foible
yeah a little bit of control well so
like he was doing drugs
and partying kind of a lot and i was
like i like can you not
and so i guess it turned into like a
mommy situation well that's not what i'm
really getting at it was more like the
you don't
work right now you don't have a job you
don't do all this all these things that
you were kind of
go you went to the laundry list and told
me all the things that you were telling
him and i was like man you just sound
like his mother
frankly like like if like and i get it
you have these actual questions and all
that [ __ ] but there's a way to go about
it and i think that you just went about
a little too
um straightforward full-on and there's
too judgy
yeah yeah and it was very like um like
you're sitting down on the bed and
getting the birds and bees talk and like
a little bit
less of like hey as a as a potential
partner
these are the things that i need and
like coming at it from like a
an angle where he could even breathe
yeah yeah but i think the fact that
he was doing drugs like he was he was
already going to be like
cut out anyway because he he's like he's
like the type of person that likes all
the party drugs like ketamine and all
this and like coke and all this other
stuff and his friends are kind of like
that too so i'm like
i think i did learn a lesson about the
controllingness of it but i think if he
was someone who kind of like had it
together then i wouldn't have felt the
need to be that
for sure if that makes sense so i get it
the situation probably it was just never
going to work well yeah if he responded
better too because you're like yo
i can't be in that environment and if he
was like okay
because i like you enough i'm not doing
that that's true because she didn't drop
all that laundry list of things on the
first time
it was over months of like hey do you
have your [ __ ] together do you care or
not
you know yeah and it was kind of like
i'm still like partying a lot
right i'd rather do ketamine and like
[ __ ] go to a party
so like it's cool to like bring it up
the first time because it is your
expectations or what you want
that's what you want and you're just
laying out what you want yeah and if he
doesn't respond the right way then
there you go you have your answer yeah
yeah or if he does respond the right way
like okay so he doesn't want to change
or he does want to make this
relationship as long as you're bringing
it up the right way
right and not like uh hey man just so
you know
like i'm putting a gun to your head
right now and a little more like um
you're you're actually trying to be with
this person right yeah
right um i have a question what's a
weird
unconventional thing that turns you on
oh
um yeah
i do i don't know why i like that so
much
you're a caretaker so you like it's
almost like she needs
his calling car like calling for him his
batman signal yeah it's like she needs
me was it just nikki though
yeah honestly it's not it's not
something that i feel like most guys
think crying is annoying
i know a guy that got boners whenever i
cried it was i find that very strange
yeah yeah it's strange it's strange i i
can't say i've i remember doing it with
other chicks though like
it's just something uniquely with nikki
also she's a [ __ ] actress
so you can like when we're in bed like i
could tell her to do things and
perform in a way and like she [ __ ]
nails it good for her she can sell it
it's
tight it's tight for role play
situations
have you guys had guys that are like
this turns around you're like really
that's so strange because i had
one guy once where we were walking
through a club and my hair like it was
so hot that i tied my hair up
while he was walking behind me he's like
that was really hot i was like
i get that it's confident it's hot to
watch a chick
like like not even know she's tying her
hair up i love that [ __ ] really yeah for
sure
oh i can't see that it's like it's like
it it's uh like it exposes the shoulders
in the neck too there's like some
probably some
like physical thing about it oh that
makes me like if i see a [ __ ] do
something like that that really makes me
want to want to [ __ ] her for sure oh
yeah because i don't want to because i'm
putting her hair
i see that chick that confident chick
and all that [ __ ] and i don't want to be
like i want to take it away also when
her hair
is like put up then it's like easier to
psych dicks
oh yeah men are trained like that like
we when we put our hair up that's when
we're about to sub your dick that's
right that's right there you go yeah yep
it's like the
the dog pavlov's thing have loves
whatever yeah
yeah i want to get in there it's like
it's like it's so you're so confident
and like so
like like all that [ __ ] that i just want
to
dick that away yeah but then like you're
fine afterwards
what takes your power from you i have a
weird thing where like if a guy is like
topless laying in bed and he just has
like one arm like this laying
i love that and i don't know why
especially when he has nice arms it's
confident it's so nice
oh it is that's right peacocking or
something peacocking
yeah and it's not like rehearse or
practice or he's not like he's just not
he's just naturally
like laying like he's actually he's just
that leisure right
i guess it's that thing too like when
guys have long sleeves on and then they
they pull up their long sleeves tattoos
and you kind of see the forearms
you're speaking gina's language i mean
with or without tattoos but
when they've got like a good meaty
forearm and they pull the sleeve up
you know kind of more towards the elbow
i'm like oh yeah i see your little
forearms
you're a little not little but i see
those meaty forearms
talking about tats too no not
necessarily either way gina is gina's
there already
yeah can you come back to us sorry
i'm back seriously you know how long
it's been
all right well that's all the time we
have today steve thank you so much for
saying thank you guys love you guys
answering our questions that we that
there are some things that we
probably didn't need to know but i'm
really glad i know that about way too
many people
there's a lot of questions a lot of
people yeah we moved on if you guys
liked this episode please give us a like
and subscribe make sure you follow steve
too we'll have all his links i mean like
i'm sure you guys know who he is i mean
it's steve green
you know so make sure you guys give us a
thumbs up
like us subscribe to us and give us five
stars on itunes
thanks for watching y'all we love you
we'll see you next week
bye don't be on things you're not
supposed to
okay don't do it talk about your
feelings it's okay talk about your
feelings